ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES
BAKER FOR JUST BRADFORD
CABALLERO CORTEZ THREE ALLEY
DODD DORADO EGGMAN GONZALEZ
DROVE HERTZBERG HUESO FURTADO
JONES BLARED LEYVA MCGUIRE
MELENDEZ MEN NEWMAN NIELSEN A
CHIRLA BOTH. PAN PORTANTINO
ROTH RUBIO SKINNER AMBERG MY
CASKEY WIENER WILK. ONE MEMBERS
OF A QUORUM IS PRESENT. MAN ASK
YOU TO PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
SO WE CAN START. WITH THE
MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS BEYOND
THE RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE RISE WE WILL BE LED IN
PRAYER THIS AFTERNOON BY
SENATOR SKINNER. AFTER WHICH
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING WE WILL
BE LED IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE. TO THE FLAG BY
SENATOR EGGMAN. SENATOR SKINNER.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS ON THIS INTERNATIONAL
WOMEN'S DAY WE RECALL THE WORDS
OF THE POET AUDRE LORDE. WHEN I
DARE TO BE POWERFUL TO USE MY
STRENGTH IN THE SERVICE OF MY
VISION THEN IT BECOMES LESSAND
LESS IMPORTANT WHETHER I AM
AFRAID. AND I WILL SHARE WITH
YOU NOW THIS PRAYER WRITTEN BY
OUR CHAPLAIN SISTER MICHELLE
GORMAN IN RECOGNITION OF
INTERNATIONAL WOMEN'S DAY.
GRACIOUS AND LOVING ALMIGHTY AS
WE ENTER A NEW MODE OF HUMAN
PRESENCE WHERE WOMEN ARE NOT
MERELY OBSERVERS. BUT WHERE
EACH CAN BE A PARTICIPANT IN
THIS MOMENT OF EVOLUTION. WE
ARE DETERMINED TO BE BOLD
PARTICIPANTS RATHER THAN TIMID
SINKS IN WAITING WE CHOOSE TO
EXERCISE THE AUTHORITY OF
HONESTY RATHER THAN TO
FEARFULLY DEFERRED TO POWER. WE
WISH TO INFLUENCE OTHERS FOR
JUSTICE RATHER THAN IMPRESS
THEM FOR GAME. AND BY YOUR
GRACE WE WILL BRING TREASURES
OF JOY FRIENDSHIP AND PEACE TO
OUR WORLD WHEN WE ALL USE OUR
STRENGTH IN THE SERVICE OF OUR
VISION. A MAN. PLEASE JOIN ME
IN THE PLEDGE READY BEGIN. I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO. SIX
AMERICAN. WHICH. HE WILL. ALL.
MEMBERS TODAY WE HAVE A
SENATORS GLACIER BAY MON AND
STERN PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATORS AND
WELCOME. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE SENATE JOURNALS
FOR THE WEEK OF MARCH FIRST TO
THE FOURTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE
WILL BE APPROVED AS CORRECTED
BY THE MINUTE CLERK. MEMBERS
ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE.
THE FIRST ITEM UP IS GOVERNOR'S
APARTMENT SOMEONE ASK YOU TO
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS SO WE
CAN GET THE BUSINESS OF THE DAY
DONE. WE'RE GONNA TAKE UP ITEM
NUMBER FIVE SENATOR BATES.
MEROM OF PRESIDENT FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE IS THE CONFIRMATION
OF HEARTYMOCKERY CHAN AND
JONATHAN J. OF SERIOUS FOR
APPOINTMENT REAPPOINTMENT TO
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
BOARD OF REGENTS MR MOCKERY
SHIAN HAVE SERVED ON THE UC
REGENTS SINCE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT HE CURRENTLY CHAIRS THE
FINANCE AND CAPITAL STRATEGIES
COMMITTEE. MISTER SURPASSES THE
CURRENT VICE CHAIR OF THE
REGION'S NATIONAL LABORATORIES
COMMITTEE WHICH OVERSEES THE
LAWRENCE LIVERMORE BERKELEY AND
LAUGHING AT LOS ALAMOS ALAMOS
NATIONAL LABORATORIES THEY WERE
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON MARCH THIRD ON A UNANIMOUS
FIVE ZERO VOTE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. IS THERE
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM SENATOR HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF MADAME
PRESIDENT I TO RISE IN SUPPORT
OF BOTH OF THESE- REGIONS TO BE
CONFIRMED FOR ANOTHER TERM ON
THE BOARD OF REGENTS. HI THE
MOCKERY SHOULD HAVE KNOWN FOR
MANY YEARS AND WAS I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO INTERVIEW HIM
WITH THE OTHER WITH THE PRO TEM
OF THE OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
RULES COMMITTEE. AND J. SERVICE
ALSO. TELL YOU YOU KNOW. MANY
OF YOU KNOW DIANNE GRIFFITHS
WHO I HOLD IN THE HIGHEST
REGARD WHO IS THE PRO TEM'S
GENERAL COUNSEL SERVED FOR MANY
YEARS AS THE- CHIEF OF STAFF TO
THE BOARD OF REGENTS. AND SHE
SPEAKS OF MISTER MOCKERY SHE
AND AS I DO IN THE HIGHEST
REGARD HE IS A DEDICATED
SERVANT HE'S WORKING AS HARD
OUT. AND OFFERS GREAT VALUE TO
THE BOARD OF REGENTS AT A TIME.
WHEN THERE'S GREAT CHALLENGES
TO THE BOARD OF REGENTS AND J.
SERVICE ALSO YOU KNOW IS
RELATIVELY NEW. ON THE BOARD
BUT HAS REALLY ENGAGE
SIGNIFICANTLY THESE ARE HARD
JOBS I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SERVE ON THAT BOARD AT ONE TIME
AND EVERY MEETING HAS ABOUT
FIFTEEN FEET OF. MATERIAL
YOU'VE GOT A REASON THESE ARE
FOLKS THAT READ IT AND OFFER
INSIGHTS AND VALUE. TO THIS
MOST IMPORTANT INSTITUTION OF
CALIFORNIA SO I STAND IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF BOTH OF THE NOMINEES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MY- SAYING
NO FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
I. ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE BATES
AYE BAKER. HI FORGES I BRADFORD
HI CAN BY ADAM HI CORTESE FIVE
DALLY. FIVE DODD I DORADO I
EGGMAN HI GONZALEZ. GROVE HI
HERTZBERG HI WITH SO HI HER
TADO HI JONES. HI WHERE'D I
LEYVA I MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S
AYE MAN HI NEWMAN HI NIELSEN.
HI A SHOW OF THE- HI PAM. FIVE
PORTANTINO FIVE ROTH HI RUBIO I
SKINNER. HI I'M BURKE RIGHT HI
WHAT CASTING. FIVE WIENER AYE
WILK HI THIS CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. GONZALEZ. I SAID I
THIRTY FIVE NO ZERO THE
APARTMENTS ARE CONFIRMED. I TO
NUMBER SEVEN SENATOR BATES.
MADAM PRESIDENT IN MEMBERS FILE
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF MICHAEL YOUNGER
AS DEPUTY SECRETARY FOR
STRATEGIC EQUITY AND PLANNING
OF THE LABOR AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY PRIOR TO
THIS APPOINTMENT MR YOUNGER WAS
ASSISTANT DIVISION CHIEF
ENTERPRISE STRATEGY AND
PERFORMANCE AT CALPERS IN THIS
ROLE HE IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
ENSURING THAT THE AGENCIES
PROCESSES PROCEDURES AND
PROGRAMS EMPOWER COMMUNITIES
HISTORICALLY AFFECTED BY THE
INEQUITIES HE WAS APPROVED IN
THE SENATE RULES COMMITTEE ON
MARCH THIRD ON A UNANIMOUS FIVE
ZERO VOTE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SINGMAN PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA HI
ATKINS FIVE BATES I BAKER FIVE
GORGEOUS I BRADFORD HI
CABALLERO HI CORTESE HI DALLY.
HI DODD. HI TO RAZA I EGGMAN HI
GONZALEZ. GROVE FIVE HERTZBERG
AYE HUESO HI HER TADO HI JONES
FIVE LAYERED. I LEYVA FIVE
MCGUIRE HI MELENDEZ I MEN HI
NEWMAN. I NIELSEN I A SHOW
ABOUT OAK. HI PAN HI PORTANTINO
HI ROTH. HI RUBIO I SKINNER. HI
I'M BURKE ALL RIGHT HI WHITE
HOUSE DECLINED FIVE WIENER. HI
WILK. HI FIVE THIRTY FIVE NO
ZERO THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED CENTERS WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO THE SENATE THIRD
READING WILL TAKE UP ITEM
NUMBER NINE SENATOR LABOR ARE
YOU PREPARED. CAN SHE IS PLEASE
READ. SENATE RESOLUTION ELEVEN
BY SENATOR LEYVA RELATIVE TO
INTERNATIONAL WOMEN'S DAY
SENATOR LEYVA THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS TODAY I
RISE TO PRESENT SENATE
RESOLUTION ELEVEN WHICH
DESIGNATES TODAY MARCH EIGHTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AS
INTERNATIONAL WOMEN'S DAY THE
FIRST NATIONAL WOMEN'S DAY WAS
OBSERVED IN THE UNITED STATES
IN NINETEEN OH NINE IN HONOR OF
THE NINETEEN OH EIGHT GARMENT
WORKERS STRIKE IN NEW YORK.
WHERE WOMEN PROTESTED THEIR
TERRIBLE WORKING CONDITIONS
THIS YEAR THE UNITED NATIONS
AND THE HOUSE THAT THE THEME
WOULD BE WOMEN IN LEADERSHIP
ACHIEVING AN EQUAL FUTURE THE
COBRA NINETEEN WORLD. THE THEME
CELEBRATE THE TREMENDOUS
EFFORTS BY WOMEN AND GIRLS
AROUND THE WORLD IN SHAPING A
MORE EQUITABLE FUTURE AND
REQUIRE COVERAGE FROM THE
COVERED NINETEEN PANDEMIC. WE
ALL KNOW THAT CODE NINETEEN HAS
A HUGE IMPACT A NEGATIVE IMPACT
ON WOMEN ACROSS THIS STATE AND
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. FROM JOB
LOSSES TO CHILD CARE
CHALLENGES. WOMEN CONTRIBUTE SO
MUCH TO OUR ECONOMY YET IN THE
LAST TEN MONTHS THE ACCOUNT FOR
FIVE POINT FOUR MILLION JOB
LOSSES. NEARLY ONE MILLION MORE
JOB LOSSES THAN MEN. IN FACT
THE NATION'S EMPLOYMENT NUMBERS
FOR DECEMBER REVEALED THAT WITH
THE EXCEPTION OF FARMERS. ALL
JOB LOSSES WERE ENTIRELY BORNE
BY WOMEN PARTICULARLY WOMEN OF
COLOR. THIS STARK REALITY IS
UNACCEPTABLE SO WE MUST ENSURE
THAT WE DO MORE TO HELP UP LIFT
ALL WOMEN. AND NOT JUST TALK
THE TALK BUT WALK THE WALK
BECAUSE AS WE ALL KNOW WHEN
WOMEN SUCCEED. EVERYONE
SUCCEEDS WHEN WOMEN ARE AT THE
TABLE EVERYONE IS AT THE TABLE.
INTERNATIONAL WOMEN'S DAY IS A
TIME TO REFLECT ON PROGRESS
MADE TO CALL FOR CHANGE TO
CELEBRATE ACTS OF COURAGE AND
DETERMINATION. ORDINARY WOMEN
WHO PLAYED EXTRAORDINARY ROLES
IN THE HISTORY OF THEIR
COUNTRIES AND COMMUNITIES
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE ON S. R. ELEVEN. I
WOULD JUST ADD THAT UP PLEASE
PICK UP YOUR BOOK IT'S
CALIFORNIA HISTORY RIGHT
OUTSIDE IT WILL TELL YOU A LOT
ABOUT WHAT WOMEN HAVE DONE HERE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
OF THE SENATE TODAY I RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SR ELEVEN
WHICH DESIGNATES MARCH EIGHTH
AS INTERNATIONAL WOMEN'S DAY AS
A WOMAN LEADER MY COMMUNITY I
KNOW HOW IMPORTANT IT IS TO BE
SUPPORTED AND HAVE YOUR VOICE
HEARD I KNOW THAT MANY WOMEN
AROUND THE WORLD OF DIFFERENT
NATIONALITIES RACES AND FAITHS
ARE STILL BATTLING TO BE HEARD
AND REPRESENT. MANY OF THEM ARE
DURING PERSECUTION HARASSMENT
JUST FOR BRADY CHALLENGING HOW
THEY AR TREATED DESPITE THE
DANGERS WOMEN CONTINUE TO BE AT
THE FOREFRONT AND FIGHTING FOR
EQUALITY I AM PROUD THAT
CALIFORNIA WOMEN HAVE BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL IN BREAKING THE
GLASS DOOR FOR ALL OF US TO
WALK THROUGH IT A SPECIAL
RECOGNITION TO OUR NEWLY
ELECTED VICE PRESIDENT CAMELOT
HERIS FIRST U. S. HOUSE SPEAKER
NANCY PELOSI FIRST FEMALE
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR LENNY COHEN
AKIS AND ARE VERY OWN DEAR
FRIEND COLLEAGUE AND LEADER
PRESIDENT. PRO TEM FROM SAN
DIEGO. BUT TODAY PARTICULAR I
ALSO WANT TO GIVE A SPECIAL
RECOGNITION TO A BRIEF
CALIFORNIANS. ARE VERY ON TREND
SAYS MEGHAN MARKLE. SHE SHOWED
STRENGTH IN THE MOST VULNERABLE
WAY BY HIGHLIGHTING AN ISSUE.
THAT AFFECTS SO MANY WOMEN AND
PEOPLE IN GENERAL ACROSS THE
WORLD. YESTERDAY SHE BRAVELY
SPOKE ABOUT HER BATTLE WITH
MENTAL HEALTH. AND SHOW THAT IT
DOESN'T MAKE YOU ANY LESS
VALUABLE. SHE IS AN EXAMPLE
WHAT IT MEANS TO BE A STRONG
WOMAN. AND TO NOT BE AFRAID TO
RECOGNIZE WHEN YOU NEED HELP.
ALL OF THESE WOMEN ARE LEADING
US THEIR INCREDIBLE CHALLENGES
IN TEACHING US INVALUABLE
LESSONS ALONG THE WAY. THE
BATTLE FOR EQUALITY FOR WOMEN
IN GOVERNMENT AND IN EVERY DAY
LIFE AROUND THE WORLD CONTINUES
AND WE MUST ALWAYS REMEMBER TO
PAY TRIBUTE TO ALL THOSE THAT
CAME BEFORE US. AND TO CONTINUE
TO LIFT EACH OTHER UP. THANK
YOU AND I ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS.
SENATOR SKINNER. THANK YOU-
MADAM PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION AND I THINK OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM CHINO FOR
BRINGING IT FORWARD. AND AS THE
VICE CHAIR OF LEGISLATIVE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS. THIS IS OUR-
COLLEAGUE WHO INTRODUCED THE
RESOLUTION POINTED OUT. WOMEN
HAVE BEEN SEVERELY HIT BY THIS
PAN SESSION. AND ECONOMIC
EQUITY IS THE FORMER FRENCH
CHALLENGE FOR US FOR WOMEN
RIGHT NOW AND SOMETHING THAT WE
AS CALIFORNIA POLICY MAKERS
HAVE TO TAKE VERY SERIOUSLY
BECAUSE THE IMPACT FROM THIS
SESSION WILL NOT ONLY BE FELT
THIS YEAR BUT FOR YEARS TO COME
ANY ESTIMATIONS ARE VERY COULD
BE. MINIMUM OF TWENTY YEARS
BEFORE WOMEN WHO EITHER LOST
THEIR JOBS OR LEFT THEIR JOBS
DURING THIS TRANSITION COME
BACK ECONOMICALLY AND WHY
BECAUSE DURING THAT TIME
THEY'RE NOT CONTRIBUTING TO
SOCIAL SECURITY THEY CANNOT
CONTRIBUTE TO ANY FOUR OH ONE
K. THEIR OWN CHILDREN OUR-
IMPACTED. FINANCIALLY THEY
THEMSELVES NOT ONLY DO TO
REDUCE THAT LESS RETIREMENT
SECURITY BUT WITHIN THEIR OWN
JOBS THEY'RE NOT ACCUMULATING
EITHER THE HOURS FOR THE
RECOGNITION TO BE ABLE TO MOVE
UP THEN IN THAT JOB SO ALL OF
THESE THINGS WILL IMPACT WOMEN
FINANCIALLY WHICH THEN IMPACTS
WHOLE FAMILY SCHOOL HOUSEHOLDS
IN THE ENTIRE STATE'S ECONOMY.
SO I WANTED TO BE VERY CLEAR
ABOUT OUR OBLIGATION TO LOOK AT
THIS ISSUE SERIOUSLY AND TO
THINK ABOUT HOW WE CAN MAKE
ECONOMIC EQUITY FOR WOMEN MORE
AT THE FOUR FRIENDS BECAUSE IT
IS THEN EQUITY FOR OUR FAMILIES
AND FOR THE WHOLE ECONOMY OF
THE STATE AND- WITHOUT I. ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS
RESOLUTION. SENATOR PAN. THANK
MADAM FOR SENT US OF THE EIGHT
YEAH LEAVE BECAUSE SIGNED PROUD
TO STAND HERE IN SUPPORT OF S.
R. ELEVEN WHAT MY GOOD FRIEND
FROM CHINO FOR BRING THIS FOR
THE FBI CAUCUS- STANDS HERE
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE WORKERS RIGHTS
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE AND CIVIL
RIGHTS FOR ALL PEOPLE
REGARDLESS OF THEIR GENDER
ETHNICITY SEXUAL ORIENTATION
DISABILITY IMMIGRATION STATUS.
TWENTY TWENTY OR CAUCUS
CONTINUE OUR EFFORTS TO DEFEND
IMMIGRANT REFUGEE COMMUNITIES
HELP EXPAND EXPAND ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE SUBSIDIES FOR
FAMILIES ADVOCATE FOR RESOURCES
FOR UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES AND
SO MUCH MORE AS WE CONFRONT THE
REALITIES OF THE WORLD WIDE
PANDEMIC INTERNATIONAL WOMEN'S
DAY IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CELEBRATE WOMEN'S LEADERSHIP
INCLUDING IN THE API COMMUNITY
WHERE- WE SEE- CONTINUING I
GAPS- AND THE OF SAMPLE HEY AND
OTHER- THAT ISSUES RELATED. TO
FOR H. I. WOMEN. BUT WELL
WRECKING- YOU KNOW IT'S IN THE-
YEAR AND A JANUARY- OUR VICE
PRESIDENT CALMLY HARRIS MADE
HISTORY ON THREE COUNTS ISSUES
AND I CARE IS THE FIRST BLACK
FOR SOUTH ASIAN. AMERICAN AND
FIRST WOMAN VICE PRESIDENT. AT
THE GOLDEN GLOBES IN FEBRUARY
CHLOE'S OUT. BECAME THE FIRST
ASIAN WOMAN AND THE ONLY SECOND
EVER WOMAN TO WIN THE PRIZE FOR
BEST DIRECTOR FOR FILM IN NO
MAN'S LAND- TIME MAGAZINE'S
INAUGURAL KID OF THE YEAR IS. A
T. TEN JELLY- ROUTE THE FIFTEEN
YEAR OLD INDIAN AMERICANS IN
COLORADO IS A BRILLIANT YOUNG
SCIENTIST AND INVENTOR WHO'S
BEEN USING TECHNOLOGY TO TACKLE
ISSUES. RANGING FROM
CONTAMINATED DRINKING WATER TO
OPIOID ADDICTION CYBERBULLYING.
AND HERE IN CALIFORNIA MANY API
WOMAN BROKE BARRIERS IN TWENTY
TWENTY WHEN THEY RAN FOR
ELECTED OFFICE- MAYOR FARRAKHAN
WAS THE FIRST INDIAN AMERICAN
MAYOR AND COUNCIL MEMBER THE
CITY OF IRVINE. MY BANK BECAME
THE FIRST ASIAN AMERICAN AMONG
WOMEN ELECTED TO MY OWN CITY IN
THE CITY SACRAMENTO CITY
COUNCIL. SO THE SORROW WAS
ELECTED AND SWORN IN AS LONG
BEACH'S FIRST CAMBODIAN
AMERICAN ON THE COUNCIL. AND
THE CITY OF LONG BEACH IS HOME
TO THE LARGEST POPULATION
BILLIONS OUTSIDE THE COUNTRY.
AND THEN OF COURSE THIS BEING
INTERNATIONAL WOMEN'S DAY
INTERNATIONALLY. SHOULD
RECOGNIZE THE- THE FIRST ONE
PRESIDENT TAIWAN SITE AND WHEN
HE WAS WIDELY PRAISED FOR HER
LEADERSHIP THROUGH COVE IT- AT
MAKE NOTE IN TAIWAN- THERE WERE
THERE SO FAR STILL UNDER
THOUSAND CASES HAVE COVETED.
AND ONLY TEN DEATHS IN CONTRAST
TO WHAT WE SEE IN OUR COUNTRY.
AND SHE WAS NAMED ONE OF THE
WORLD'S ONE HUNDRED MOST
POWERFUL WOMEN BY FORBES IN
TWENTY TWENTY. AND THEN TELL IN
JAPAN TOKYO'S GOVERNOR YURIKO
KOIKE EIGHT THE CITY'S FIRST
WOMAN GOVERNOR CAPTURED 60% OF
THE VOTE. TO WIN HER RE
ELECTION IN A LANDSLIDE. ON A
MORE PERSONAL THAT I'VE DO ON
ALL RECORD. A ON MY OWN STAFF
MY CHIEF STAFF AND WRECKED BEEN
WITH SINCE MY FIRST TERM IN THE
STATE ASSEMBLY AND NOW OF
COURSE OF LEADERSHIP ROLES IN
MY- OFFICE AS WELL AS MY PRESS
SECRETARY HAS BEEN WITH ME
SINCE I. FIRST WAS SWORN INTO
THE SENATE. AND AS A CERTAINLY
AS WE LOOK AROUND THIS VERY
CHAMBER I WANT WE SEE WOMEN WHO
TRULY EMBRACE LEADERSHIP.
VALUES POGRESS PASSION. SO
AGAIN I WANT TO PROUD TO STAND
IN SUPPORT OF THIS VERY
IMPORTANT RESOLUTIONS WE
CELEBRATE YOU AND THE WOMEN WHO
FIGHT TO INSPIRE MAKE A
DIFFERENCE EVERYWHERE- I DON'T
DENY THAT. THANK YOU. SENATOR
DRUGS OF. THANK YOU MANAGER I
AM VERY PROUD TO CO AUTHOR S.
R. ELEVEN NIGHT VERY MUCH THANK
THE COAT THE AUTHOR. BECAUSE
SHE ALWAYS SPEAKS WITH SUCH
PASSION ON THESE ISSUES AND WE
ARE VERY GRATEFUL FOR THAT- IN
NINETEEN ELEVEN THE TRIANGLE
SHIRTWAIST FACTORY IN NEW YORK
CITY. BURNED TO THE GROUND. AND
KILLED A HUNDRED FORTY FIVE
WORKERS WERE LOCKED INSIDE. HE
WAS A TRAGEDY THAT BROUGHT
WIDESPREAD ATTENTION TO THE
DANGEROUS WHAT CHUCK CONDITIONS
OF FACTORIES. ANTI WORKER
POLICIES FIELD THE CONDITIONS
DIDN'T HELP THEY FEEL THE
CONDITIONS THAT LED TO THE FIRE.
YOUNG IMMIGRANT WOMEN WERE PAID
FIFTEEN DOLLARS A WEEK. FOR
TWELVE HOUR DAYS SEVEN DAYS A
WEEK SEWING AND CRAMPED SPACES.
WHEN THE INTERNATIONAL LADIES
GARMENT WORKERS UNION LED A
STRIKE IN NINETEEN OH NINE THEY
WERE RETALIATED AGAINST AND
EVEN IMPRISONED. THE FIRE
UNITED THE GARMENT WORKERS
ACROSS THE CITY AND LEAD TO
LAWS AND REGULATIONS TO
PROTECT. THE SAFETY OF THOSE
WORKERS. THAT WAS A MOVEMENT
FOLLOWED THE THAT MOVEMENT
FOLLOWED THE PATH BLAZED BY
OTHER WOMEN LIKE LUCY GONZALEZ
PARSONS IN EIGHTEEN EIGHTY SIX.
THIS WOMAN BLACK MEXICAN WOMAN
LED THE DEMAND FOR THE EIGHT
HOUR WORKDAY. SHE LED IN-CHICAGO AND FILL THE STREETS
AND MORE THAN A HUNDRED
THOUSAND MARCHED IN OTHER
CITIES. RIGHT NOW THIS IS FAST
FORWARD. RIGHT NOW LOS ANGELES
HAS THE HIGHEST CONCENTRATION%
THE GARMENT INDUSTRY WORKERS IN
THE COUNTRY. WITH MORE THAN
FORTY FIVE THOUSAND PEOPLE
INCLUDING IMMIGRANT WOMEN.
A DAY CUTTING SEWING AND DYING
CLOTHING INCLUDING FACE MASKS
AND OTHER PP. MANY AT AN
AVERAGE OF FIVE DOLLARS AN HOUR.
MILLIONS IN WAGES ARE STOLEN
FROM THESE WOMEN AND THEIR
FAMILIES. HE HAS ALSO MADE THE
INDUSTRY HOSPITAL ETHICAL
GARMENT COMPANIES TRYING TO
ELIMINATES WORKSHOPS. AND
ENSURE THAT CODING QUOTE MADE
IN THE USA REPRESENTS QUALITY
AND JUSTICE NOW MORE THAN EVER
WE NEED TO FOLLOW THE EXAMPLE
IN THE BRAVERY OF THE
TRAILBLAZING WOMEN I ALSO ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. CENTER CENTER-
CHAU BOTH. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. ARE RISING SUPPORTING A
PROUD CO AUTHOR OF SENATE
RESOLUTION RESOLUTION ELEVEN
INTERNATIONAL WOMEN'S DAY.
INTERNATIONAL WOMEN'S DAY IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL OF US TO
CELEBRATED ACKNOWLEDGED THE
CONTRIBUTION OF SO MANY GREAT
WOMEN WHO HAVE LED BY EXAMPLE.
I PERSONALLY THINK OF MY
GRANDMOTHER'S TO FACE GREAT
HARDSHIPS IN THEIR LIVES AS
FEMALES IN MEXICO. YOU SEE.
BOTH MY GRANDMOTHERS WERE BORN
AND RAISED IN MEXICO BOTH WAYS%
ARE FAMILIES PARTIALLY IN
MEXICO ONE OF THEM IMMIGRATED
TO THE U. S. AND IT IS THROUGH
HER EXAMPLE HER LEADERSHIP. AND
HER STRENGTH SHE WASN'T ELECTED
HE WASN'T SOMEONE THAT HOLD OFF
HELD OFFICE- IT WAS A TEACHER
IN HER IN HER YEARS PRIOR TO
GETTING MARRIED AND HAVING HER
OWN FAMILY AND IT WAS HER
DETERMINATION HER LEADERSHIP.
HER VALUES HER CHARACTER WHO
BELIEVE IN FAMILY THAT ALLOWED
HER CHILDREN IMMIGRATED HERE
FIVE ORIGINALLY BECAUSE THEY
WERE UNDER AGE INTO EVENTUALLY
WHEN THEY WERE OLDER. TO COME
TO THIS COUNTRY AND THROUGH HER
LEADERSHIP WAS ABLE TO INSPIRE
HER CHILDREN TO USE EDUCATION
AS A MEANS TO OPPORTUNITY TO
ACHIEVE THE AMERICAN DREAM. I'M
A PRODUCT OF THAT TREE. REFER
TO THEM INTO SOMEONE LIKE MY
MOTHER WHO IMMIGRATED THE AGE
OF EIGHTEEN. WHO BEGAN TO LEARN
ENGLISH. AS A SECOND LANGUAGE
AT THAT AGE. HER INSPIRATION
HER GARDENS. HER PASSION TO
ADVOCATE FOR THOSE THAT ARE
UNDER REPRESENTED IN THIS
COUNTRY. I HAVE STRONG WOMEN IN
MY FAMILY. AND LET ME TELL YOU
I THINK OF MY GRANDMOTHER FOR
MEXICO MY MOTHER'S MOTHER WHEN
THE THING IS WE DIDN'T HAVE
MUCH OPPORTUNITY WAS TAKEN OUT
OF SCHOOL AT THE AGE OF EIGHT
THIRD GRADE BECAUSE HER FATHER
BELIEVE THAT THERE WAS NO NEED
FOR HER TO CONTINUE HER
EDUCATION BECAUSE SHE WAS GOING
TO GET MARRIED AND HAVE
CHILDREN. BUT YOU SEE. I TAKE
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THEIR EFFORTS AS WELL BECAUSE
THESE WOMEN MAY NOT NECESSARILY
HAVE BEEN TAUGHT AT SCHOOL
FORMALLY. THEY HAD VALUES WE
HAD CHARACTER AND IT WAS THOSE
VALUES AND THOSE CHARACTERS AND
LET THEIR CHILDREN TO BECOME
GREAT. PARTICIPANTS OTHER
COMMUNITIES. IT IS THOSE VALUES
AND A GRANDMOTHER WHO MIGHT
LIVE WITHIN MEXICO. BUT ALLOWED
ME TO BE WHO I AM TODAY AS A
PERSON AND I STAND HERE. ON THE
SENATE FLOOR. IT IS AMAZING
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WHICH
BALLOTS OPPORTUNITIES. I THINK
OF MY DAUGHTERS WHO NOW GET TO
BENEFIT FROM THE COURAGE OF
THESE TWO WOMEN WELL THREE
INCLUDING MY MOTHER. TO ALLOW
ME TO BE HERE. THERE WAS NO
EASY FEAT. BUT THEY NEVER ALLOW
THE HARDSHIPS TO DETER THEIR
SPIRITS OVER THERE DR. BUT THE
PASSING THOSE VALUES A
STEADFAST DETERMINATION TO ME.
AND I HOPE TO PASS THIS ON
VALUES TO ON TO MY CHILDREN.
THIS IS WHERE RISE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS RESOLUTION. AND
I ENCOURAGE ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES TO JOIN ME IN VOTING
FOR ESTARá ELEVEN. IT IS
BETTER LOOKING KID IS. THE MOON
INTERNATIONAL. LOOK MODEST
ENOUGH OF WHAT HE DOES CAN BY
LORD ENOUGH ON THE- GET TO GOD
I DIDN'T CONSUME BY LARA. ARE
YOU THEN I CAN TO SEE HER SON
THAT A LOT DAY. BONTA TO BROKER
BY BOOKING SYSTEM YEARS.
IDENTIFIED THAT'S AVAILABLE
THIS GOING SOMEWHERE HE KNOW.
HE NEED I DON'T KNOW IF I USE.
A STORY A KEY AND IS ANOTHER.
MINNESOTA CAL. TODAY IS A VERY
GOOD. GET ON. BOTH OF NAY THAT
TWO. WHAT EFFECT HE SAID HIM TO
BUY THIS IS BUT IS THIS IN THE
HOME TO GET THE NEW MOST OUT
THE BODY OF BUILDING BOTH OF
THE FEE BUT A THE IS IN A LOT
OF FOCUS ON THE BUT STILL SOON
BUT IT'S ANOTHER. ON FIFTH
GRAPHICS. NOT ONLY IN THE STATE
NOT ONLY IN THIS COUNTRY. BUT
AROUND THE WORLD IT IS OFTEN
TATED THAT IT'S A MAN'S WORLD
BUT WE MUST AGREE. ON AND MAKES
THE WORLD GO ROUND A WOMAN
MAKES EVERYTHING COME TOGETHER.
COMPLETELY SO WE THANK WOMEN
WHO NOT ONLY. BIRTH OUR
CHILDREN REYES DON'T BUT ALSO
HAVE TAKEN A TREMENDOUS ROLE IN
THE WORKPLACE THAT HAD
TREMENDOUS IMPACT ON EVERYTHING
THAT WE DO IN SOCIETY FROM THE
AMAZING WOMEN FROM HIDDEN
FIGURES DOROTHY VAUGHAN MARY
WALKER- AND- KELLY HI
KATHERINE- WALKER ME NOW.
CATHERINE JOHNSON- TWO PEOPLE
LIKE SHIRLEY CHISHOLM ELEANOR
ROOSEVELT. O'CLOCK WITH WHOM
WE'VE BEEN EDUCATION HERE IN
THIS. WE CAN GO ON AND ON AND
ON RECOGNIZING THOSE WOMEN
WHO'VE HAD A TREMENDOUS IMPACT
WE RECOGNIZE OUR OWN-
COMMENTAIRES WHO'S NOW THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF THESE GREAT UNITED
STATES AND I WOULD BE REMISS IF
I DON'T RECOGNIZE THE YOUNG
POET LAUREATE MISS AMANDA
GORMAN WHO IS CONTINUING TO
HAVE AN IMPACT THE DAILY ON
WHAT WE DO IN THIS COUNTRY SO.
ON BEHALF OF LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS I ASKED HER AYE VOTE ON
ARTS S. R. ELEVEN. SEEING NO
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SENATOR LEYVA YOU MAY CONCLUDE.
IT WAS A THANK YOU TO ALL MY
COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR WONDERFUL
COMMENTS AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. IF THERE IS NO
OBJECTION THIS. IS ELIGIBLE FOR
A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SAYING
THAT NONE. FIVE THIRTY FIVE NO
ZERO MEASURE PASSES.
GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS WE ARE GOING
TO FILE ITEM TEN SENATOR
CABALLERO. MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION SIXTEEN BY SENATOR
CABALLERO RELATIVE TO WOMEN IN
CONSTRUCTION WEEK SENATE
CABALLERO THANK YOU MR A MADAM
PRESIDENT I RISE TO PRESENT
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
SIXTEEN WHICH DECLARES MARCH
SEVENTH THROUGH THE THIRTEENTH
AS WOMEN IN CONSTRUCTION WEEK.
MEMBER OF THE LEGISLATIVE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS AND THEN MADE
WOMEN'S HISTORY MONTH I'M PROUD
TO DECLARE THE LEGISLATURE
SUPPORT FOR PROGRAMS AND
POLICIES THAT PROMOTE AN
EQUITABLE WORKPLACE FOR WOMEN.
S. C. R. SIXTEEN CELEBRATES
WOMEN WORKERS AS AN ESSENTIAL
COMPONENT OF THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY AND ENCOURAGES
POLICYMAKERS TO ENACT
LEGISLATION THAT WILL INCREASE
THEIR PRESENCE IN THE WORK
FORCE. IN THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY WOMEN BATTLE WIDELY
RECOGNIZED GENDER RELATED
CHALLENGES SUCH AS GENDER
BIASES SEXUAL HARASSMENT LACK
OF ADEQUATE RESOURCES AND
BENEFITS AND SOCIAL PREJUDICES.
OF ALL TEN MILLION PEOPLE
EMPLOYED IN THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY ONLY 9% OF THE WORKERS
ARE WOMEN THE HIGHEST HIGHEST
REPORTED PERCENT TO DATE. WE
CAN AND MUST DO BETTER THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY PROVIDES
OPPORTUNITIES FOR WOMEN TO
ACHIEVE FINANCIAL SECURITY
DESPITE FACING UNDER
REPRESENTATION WOMEN IN THE
CONSTRUCTION SECTOR EARN ON
AVERAGE ABOUT 95% OF WHAT THEIR
MALE COUNTERPARTS MAKE THEM
NEARLY ELIMINATING THE GENDER
WAGE GAP. BY COMPARISON AT THE
NATIONAL LEVEL WOMEN IN THE U.
S. EARN ONLY 81% OF WHAT THEIR
MALE COUNTERPARTS MAKE. S. YEAR
SIXTEEN RECOGNIZES THAT
CALIFORNIA CAN MEET ITS
INFRASTRUCTURE GOALS BY
ACKNOWLEDGING WOMEN AS AN
UNTAPPED RESOURCE TO HELP CLOSE
THE SKILLED LABOR GAP. WE KNOW
THERE IS AN ENORMOUS NEED FOR
NEIGHBORS IN CALIFORNIA AND THE
CONSTRUCTION WORKFORCE IS
SHRINKING FOR EVERY FIVE
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS LEAVING
THE WORK FORCE THERE IS ONLY
ONE IN THE IN THE PIPELINE TO
REPLACE THEM. WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY EDUCATE AND INSPIRE
WOMEN TO PURSUE REWARDING
CAREER OPPORTUNITIES IN
CONSTRUCTION AND THE TRADES.
THROUGHOUT THE CUPBOARD
NINETEEN PANDEMIC CONSTRUCTION
HAS REMAINED AN ESSENTIAL
INDUSTRY HIGHLIGHTING ITS
IMPORTANT ROLE WITHIN OUR
SOCIETY. THE SHORTAGE OF WOMEN
IN CONSTRUCTION PRESENTS THE
INDUSTRY THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
WOMEN TO CONTRIBUTE A BROADER
OTHERWISE AND CONSIDERED
PERSPECTIVE. IMPROVE TEAM
PERFORMANCE AND SEEK
PROFESSIONAL GROWTH IN WAYS
THAT WERE TRADITIONALLY
UNAVAILABLE. CONVINCING WOMEN
THAT CAN THRIVE AND CAN EXPECT
RESPECT AND SUPPORT AS A WORKER
IN THE CONSTRUCTION AND THE
TRADE INDUSTRY IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT AND WON'T HAPPEN
OVERNIGHT. IT'S A LONG GAME BUT
I KNOW THAT THE LEADERSHIP IN
THE TRADES ARE COMMITTED TO
THIS CHANGE AND WITH
PERSISTENCE WE CAN ENSURE THAT
MORE WOMEN BECOME TRAINED. AND
HIRED IN THIS IMPORTANT
INDUSTRY FOR THOSE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU SIR CABALLERO
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARINGNONE
MEMBERS THIS IS A CANDIDATE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL VOTE. THERE
IS NO OBJECTION FIVE THIRTY
FIVE NO ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED THANK YOU SENATOR
CABALLERO. MEMBERS WE ARE NOW
GOING TO MOVE TO COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS. CENTER CORTESE.
BOTH THANK YOU RICHARD THE
COMMITTEE ON LABOR PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT RETIREMENT WILL BE
MEDIAN ROOM OF FOUR TWO OH
THREE UPON ADJOURNMENT OF FOR
SESSION THANK YOU CENTER
CORTESE. MEMBERS THAT THERE IS
NO FURTHER BUSINESS SENATOR
ATKINS THE DISCUSS CLEAR MAN
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND- LET ME. HOPEFULLY MY
COLLEAGUES WILL JOIN ME IN
RECOGNIZING WE HAD THREE
BIRTHDAYS- SINCE WE WERE LAST
TOGETHER. THE GOOD SENATOR FROM
IRVINE THE GOOD SENATOR FROM
SANGER AND THE GOOD SENATOR
FROM FRESNO ALL CELEBRATED
BIRTHDAYS THIS PAST WEEKEND SO.
JOIN ME IN WISHING THEM A VERY
HAPPY BIRTHDAY. HI LOOK FORWARD
TO SEEING ALL OF YOU BETWEEN
NOW AND THURSDAY- A LOT OF WORK
WILL OCCUR BETWEEN NOW AND THEN
BUT THURSDAY MARCH ELEVENTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AT NINE AM
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT. THE
MATTER PRO TEMP THE SENATE WILL
BE N RECESS UNTIL THREE THIRTY
AT WHICH TIME THE GERMAN
GOVERNMENT MOTION WILL BE MADE.
WE WILL CONVENE THURSDAY AT
NINE AM HAVE A GREAT DAY
MEMBERS.